this thing has leaked into everything
and as i promised this show is about the
endless insanity that is everywhere here
is biden education secretary miguel
angel cardona defending uh dudes with
penises in women's sports
do you believe it's fair or not for
biological boys
to compete against girls in sports it's
a simple question
i believe all students should have
access to a sport
so you do you do support biological boys
competing against girls in sports
i believe i answered the question no you
haven't just it's a simple question just
answer the question you either the
administration either supports it or you
don't you're saying do i believe
transgender uh girls should have access
to sports yes i do complete clown joe
these people are just ridiculous clowns
listen i keep saying they don't deserve
your attention they deserve your
complete mockery and that's it there are
differences between boys and girls
that's how it is okay
generally speaking guys are bigger guys
are stronger the worst nba player the
worst guy in the nba there is a guy on
some nba team i don't watch the nba
anymore because it's gone woke there's a
guy somewhere in the nba who is the 12th
man on the worst team in the league
averaging probably one point a game if
that he would be the mvp of the wnba
that does not mean that women cannot
love basketball and be quite good at
basketball when i was in high school i
went to the same high school as sue bird
sue bird was a multiple wnba
mvp i was a couple years older than her
but i played with her on the court
in the local park a couple times she was
running circles around guys that's
pretty great but generally speaking the
best wnba player would would never even
make it to the nba i am 45 with a torn
acl and i'm going to put on a dress and
i'm going to be in the wnba wasn't there
a movie about what was that movie uh
jumana jumana what was it come on connor
you're the only one that gets my
references around here lately jumana
juwanna play me what was it called the
movie about the the guy
who became a wnba player he was a
washout juwanna play me jumanji
jumama come on
joanna man okay thank you there was a
move thank you very much jesus anyway
these people are absolutely ridiculous
and we can make fun of it but then
there's this other part of it that
actually is very serious so here's the
education secretary basically saying
that teachers rights come before
parental rights
do you believe that school districts
should keep a child's involvement and
gender transition a secret from their
parents
sir i
i would love to answer questions on the
budget which is why i'm here and i i
think what what i'm saying
these are policies that your
administration stands by and you're
asking me to fund your budget
and these are policies that you stand
for
it's completely relevant to why you're
here today it's a simple question and
answer the question do you think the
schools
should keep it a secret from their
parents
if their children are involved in gender
transition parents listen parents in
schools must work together to support
students and i do strongly support and
if you look through the work that we've
uh supported and in our policies and our
practices we want parents should schools
ever keep that a secret from parents
excuse me
should schools ever keep it a secret
from parents
if their children are involved
in gender transition school should only
be a secret from parents schools should
be partnering with parents in
communication and there are times where
schools uh are
working and supporting students on
issues that are very sensitive
it's vile it's disgusting and you must
get your children out of
public schools to the best of your
ability and i know it is not easy for
everybody and not everyone can afford a
private school or a charter school this
is why we should be funding students
instead of systems but if you think that
guy and the rest of these crazy woke
activists have your kids best interests
in mind and if you want your second
grade daughter to be talking to a male
or female teacher about straight or gay
sex or about gender transitioning or the
rest of it man you're like as apparent
to me i honestly i cannot even imagine i
cannot even imagine where your head
could be at if you think that's okay but
they are pushing this this is the policy
of the administration which is why that
guy comes off as such a waffling fool he
can't
answer anything honest honestly because
he knows that the honest answer is yes
of course he is for the state having
more power over the children the state
being able to privately talk to kids
about all of this gender stuff and not
report it to the parents we've got some
info here from rebel news on what the
administration is doing the biden
administration announced in may that k
through 12 schools must allow boys into
girls bathrooms in order to qualify for
federal funds used to pay for school
lunches the move which was made by the
u.s department of agriculture's food and
nutrition service was made based on the
interpretation of the prohibition on
discrimination based on sex as detailed
in title ix of the education amendments
of 1972 as well as the food and
nutrition act of 2008. so you got it
that's what they'll do that's what the
policy of this administration is the
policy flatly is we're going to put boys
and girls bathrooms we're going to put
girls in boys bathrooms we're going to
be able to hide information from you as
parents we're going to talk to them
about all this gender identity nonsense
and it is just not going to stop this so
this is exactly where i would say to my
my good liberal friends hey you guys
voted for this you guys thought that
biden was not you know like bernie in
the lunatics but here he is so where
where are you right now are you speaking
up about it are you going to vote for
this guy again do you have any regrets
over the last couple years